let's talk about a serious topic playboy
releases october covering featuring a
man go ahead let me say that one more
time
october's uh uh issue of playbook
playboy is a uh man
uh 201 digital governor future bretman
rock a 23 year old male social media
influencer originally from the
philippines as bret mann the company
said on twitter when they unveiled the
october cover friday attached
to the post was a short video bret man
dressed in a woman's lingerie in heels
with a bow tie and bunny ears completing
the look rock
rose to fame as an influencer on youtube
and vine later releasing his own line of
makeup to go along with the makeup
tutorial videos he often posts
appearance on the playboy cover will not
be the first time he has appeared on a
magazine cover having previously been
seen on the cover of gay times in 2019.
so why playboy over playgirl i want to
get your insight i think you have the
best insight have you have you ever seen
him do his social media i've seen him on
different videos he is legit hilarious
so before i get into like why i think
this is definitely very wrong and not
cool at all man
uh he's hilarious and my ex-girlfriend
used to love him and watched uh his
stuff
but this is where playboy's at now this
is how tarnished their brand is this is
how irrelevant they are that they're
looking for something
to get them out of the dumpster fire
that playboy is now
they had i don't know we've talked about
on the podcast what you could buy
playboy brand for and turn it around and
turn into something freaking awesome
but this is where they're going now
they're taking the gay dude putting him
in heels
and throwing him on the cover not play
girl
play boy
hugh would be turning in his grave right
now and on someone who has partied in
the playboy mansion a few times
there's a lot
better stuff out there to pick from than
the bret man i'm just letting you know i
wonder what the girls think
seriously because it is a competition
right as a model yeah you know they took
they took their
jobs supporting women
my first reaction is why not play girl
now you know what you you said that
first yeah i i asked the question but
you brought that up yesterday when he
said why not play girl over playboy but
then also
um
is it selling
you know is there numbers that support
you know what i mean like is it a
magazine would we be talking about it
would we be talking about it look it's
true no it works i couldn't care less
man is this still more than anything
else is this still shocking to us
like is it i'll be honest when i saw
miss mrs nevada i was shocked i was like
that's that that's
and then i thought like wow you know
that i felt bad for biological women
because i'm like man
this is a this is a a
a miracle of surgery right what's his
nevada what was that mrs nevada is a uh
transgender woman now who won mrs nevada
um you know very beautiful and all that
but i mean like that was shocking in
who it was right
uh
whereas this this playboy thing to me is
just it's it's a police understand it's
a gimmick yeah that is that's that's yep
it's missing nevada so
yeah that that to me like vegas baby
yeah if that was on now if that was on
the if if she was on the cover of
playboy would that even raise an eyebrow
would we talk about it you know like i'm
i'm sorry is it a good thing that i'm so
desensitized but is that one big nothing
burger but i guess we're in society i
mean we're just like okay so whatever is
just gonna be clickbait and uh something
that we can just talk about it doesn't
matter what it is then huh i got stats
here here's a playboy magazine i'm
purely looking at business
demos this is the playboy magazines
demographics if you can flip it so the
audience can see david
so male 83
female female 17.3 percent okay fine
age 18 to 24 a quarter
25 to 34 another quarter 35 to 44 21
45 to 54 15 and a half percent so say 18
to 54 is majority of their market 9.7
above 55 watch playboy okay
look at playboy household income 16 make
six figures that's pretty solid by the
way people with money subscribe to
playboy marital status 40 are married
45 percent are single and you got the
res full-time professional management
student that's subscribing to the
content so now
if this is a publicity stunt for for
getting people to talk about it am i
gonna go buy it
if i'm getting publicity on this i'm
probably not gonna buy it do you
understand what i'm saying i don't know
if this kind of publicity gets me to buy
it
if it's to attract a new audience okay
cool yes you're doing it if you are
trying to attract a new audience but
that new audience isn't as big of an
audience as people think it's less than
one percent that you're looking at it as
an audience so if you
jerry springer years ago had was doing
his jre jre jerry and one day says i'm
smarter than this i know politics i used
to be mayor of cincinnati before i cut
that check to that lady but i'm a mayor
i know politics i should have my own
show and he started talking about
serious issues in his morning show his
numbers plummeted you know what they
realized who are your viewers
is mothers and wives that are staying
home that just want to be entertained
for the time that you got what are you
doing talking about serious issues
that's the last thing they want to hear
you talk about and you lost your
audience so
we're gonna find that if in the next six
twelve eighteen months if playboy bank
file saw another bankruptcy again they
totally disrespected their audience but
if this thing takes off listen maybe
they were targeting an audience that we
were not it does it reeks of desperation
it does reek of desperation for sure i
agree with you yeah
this seems like it's a publicity stunt
but nobody like by the way when you were
reading the stats that just like
everyday american
you know 30 year old guy makes 60 grand
a year
you know maybe he's married maybe he's
not just wants to see a hot chick see
some titties yeah all good have a have a
beer see some titties all good
now i gotta see this
seven o'clock adam is by far and away my
favorite house so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]